[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Mo sous tous les cieux en toute saison
quand s'allume les premiers néons je
vais retrouver mon grand
patron le cirque
point perdu dans le flot des passants
qui va vers lui je sens mon sang qui se
réveillant le
voyant le
cirque
j'ai taille moyenne n moyen signe
distinctif néant
et pour tous les gens je ne suis rien et
rien pour les petits
enfants moi unel
on me regarde sans me voir on ne rie pas
de mes histoires on s'en moque on est
venu voir le
C une table de
maquillage de l'or du rouge et puis du
bleu il m'en faut pas
davantage uneit aller les plein faux et
Je deviens moi le
[Applaudissements]
PL mon costume extravagant sous le T
tourdisant de bravos je bondis dans le
CIR moi les clown je joue du violon du
saxo je fais des bons je fais des saut
encevé le
chapitaux du cirque
là je jongle avec étoil signe distinctif
géant je vois briller toutes ces étoiles
dans les yeux des petits
enfants
moi je suis celui qui peut devenir le
plus beau de le
un demiieu sur son
navire le
CIR à minuit finit le
miracle quand je regagne mon
hôtel je suis redevenu un
tel un tel jusqu'au prochain spectacle
oui mais demain moi
dans mon costume extravagant sous le
tonur étourdissant de brav j'
dans alors les
petits vous êtes venu voir votre am
Auguste oui ah c'est très bien les
petits oh
[Musique]
bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci merci